donc c'est une série
temporelle de la température
du montrer ça vaut pour résoudre des
énigmes autour du climat le principe de
cette escale games scientifique
organisée par le laboratoire des
sciences du climat et de l'environnement
objectif sortir de cet espace en
trouvant les indices dissimulés ils sont
sur les traces d'une chercheuse qui a
été enfermée en 2053 dans la carothèque
suite à une très très forte canicule
elle s'est volontairement fermé parce
que après plusieurs jours voire semaines
de canicule à des températures
supérieures à 15 1 de pessac ligne
baptisation est tombé en panne c'est aux
participants de comprendre de trouver
les indices pour à sa place à elle
trouvé comment sortir et tous ces
indices sont en lien avec l'histoire du
climat cette escale games une animation
organisée à gif-sur-yvette dans le cadre
des visites insolites du cnrs et de la
30e édition de la fête de la science
plus précisément dans la carothèque du
laboratoire des sciences du climat et de
l'environnement un lieu rempli de
mystères et d'histoire climatique la
carothèque ça va être un lieu dans
lequel on va stocker des carottes ici
des carottes de sédiments de sédiments
marins qui ça va être tout ce qui va se
déposer au fond de l'océan au fur et à
mesure du temps dans lesquels on peut
comprendre et en les analysant des
climats qu'il écumait a passé au total
dix scientifiques et climatologues le
temps d'un après-midi ont participé à
cette animation
c'était très intéressant des paysans
parce que c'est pas des endroits où on a
l'habitude de rentrer
et puis un super accompagnement dans
l'équipe sur place ça permet de
découvrir des choses en moi je suis en
manque déjà on peut dans le domaine des
sciences de la terre du coup ça m'était
familier mais même si on est pas
familier c'était très ludique on s'est
beaucoup amusé
résultat ils ont réussi à sortir de la
carothèque en moins d'une heure leur
cadeau un jeu de société sur la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique pour
continuer l'aventuré écologique